all right folks x-men not the one that
they're making right now they're
currently shooting x-men Days of Future
past I have gone back and re-watched the
original x-men and I think that's
probably gonna kick off my revisiting
and just sort of look at them now
through the lens of what's happened
since this isn't really a review it's
more of a look back and the first thing
kind of noticed doesn't hold up as well
as as I would have thought I don't mean
in terms of special effects I mean
special effects a age that happens but
the feel of the thing doesn't hold up
now x-men when it came out in 2000 it
set the bar at the time for both
superhero movies and specifically for
superhero teen movies and so how much
has changed since then new bars have
been set that first one was really good
when it came out I mean it was it was
bold it embraced the comic book elements
yet made them feel grounded and
believable and it was something new and
exciting as far as comic-book movies
went now looking back on it it's kind of
clunky first of all the movie is an
exposition machine I mean everybody just
talk and talk and - I mean Professor
Xavier so he's exposition on wheels
it doesn't seem it doesn't want to be a
teen movie it wants to be a Wolverine
movie but it's got to put everybody else
in there cuz you know the because Fox
didn't feel Wolverine could carry the
movie on his own yeah they thought later
he could we all saw how that turned out
but it's Wolverines movie it's
Wolverines franchise really in hindsight
you know all the other characters are
there but they're just kind of there the
focus is always on him there's just sort
of a feel where everybody seems slightly
trepidatious I mean that they all
embrace their characters about as well
as they could at that point playing them
all for the first time but you kind of
get the feel watching out that everybody
knew what they were trying to do was
something that
worked up to that point and very well
might not work now you sort of feel that
slight you know walking you to the water
going oh it's cold you get to get that
feel a little bit from the from the
performers and from the film in general
another thing that was interesting to
look back on and think about is just how
big the continuity gap between x-men and
x-men first classes because you've got
lines like Professor X saying that may
need to helped him build cerebro well
when we see first class we see that well
neither of them really built cerebro was
an existing thing that they got brought
into Wow that's sort of a spin on what I
actually have them but cool fine
whatever you so that I can kind of
accept but there are a lot more specific
things like Professor X saying that he
met magneto when he was 17 nope there's
you know the whole thing with mystique
being involved with Professor X in their
youth if she's got that history with him
the danger she puts him into and she
sabotages cerebro now seems a little bit
mm-hmm
really a hint of remorse but again I
mean think they couldn't no I'm not
blaming x-men for this but what I'll
kind of be interested to see is whether
they make any attempt to reconcile those
issues with Days of Future past because
it is gonna deal with alternate timeline
not that I'm saying they should devote
any serious screen time to covering up
these few little continuity gaps you
know what they're not that important but
the story that they're doing presents
that opportunity anyway you can't even
accept
should we have to hide you can't even
accept yourself
should if you have to you can't even
accept yourself
we have to